[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu es toujours à la
peine
matelau et ce d'amour que tu
aimes ton
bateau et lasse-moi la vie
mondaine c'est mon L
mais si un jour me disait je t'aime un
beau
matelot je lui ferai la vaisselle lui
ferai le BF grosselle je lui tiendrai sa
maison je lui ferai la cuisine j'irai
même à l'usine je serai toujours sur le
pont je lui ferai le ménage et pour
qu'il se ménage avant le boss miranton
je lui dirai matelot va prendre l'apé
mais ne force pas trop car sur la terre
on est pas sur l'eau repos matelot je
lui dirai matelot va prendre laap mais
ne force pas trop car sur la terre on
est pas sur l'eau repos
[Applaudissements]
matelot tu es toujours à
l'ouvrage
Matot moi les Palace
voyage c'est
Mo les diamants et les
parure c'est bien
beau mais s' me faisait vivre la dur un
beau
matelau j'éplucherai les patates cerai
les savattes je ferai tout dans la
maison passai les cravates m'occuperai
de la chatte pleurerai sur les
oignons je serai son équipage et pour
qu'il se ménage en lui brossant son
vaisson je lui dirai matelot va prendre
laap mais le force pas trop car sur la
Peron les pas sur le repos matelot je
lui dirai matelot va prendre laap mais
ne force pas trop quand une femme du
monde est au boulot repos mat
alors tu es bienens
oui